Republican backlash is growing against
president Trump's 12 billion dollar plan
to help American farmers feeling the
pain of the escalating trade war
the president's proposal was announced
yesterday in response to retaliatory
tariffs imposed by China and other
countries some GOP lawmakers blame mr.
Trump's trade policies for the problem
they've been taking the legs out from
under America's farmers and ranchers
what the administration is offering them
instead is 12 billion dollars of
gold-plated crutches that's not what
anybody wants I just don't think the
tariff route is the smart way to go
Adriana Diaz spoke with one Illinois
farmer who voted for President Trump and
said he's now on the front lines of the
president's trade war she's at the
soybean farm in wil County outside
Chicago Adriana good morning good
morning up to 80 percent of soybeans
like these farmed here in wil County are
exported to Asia and mostly to China
with the 25 percent tax or tariff
China's imposed on us soybeans like
these have different prices down about
$2 per bushel for farm of this size that
means tens of thousands of dollars in
losses for a trade war driven by the
highest levels of government
this year's soybean crop could be a
record harvest for farmer Dave Kessel
how far along are these they're further
along than they normally would be this
time of year but he could lose money
right now we're looking at beans used to
be 10 bucks now they're down to 8 bucks
that's that's a 20% pay cut basically on
Tuesday President Trump asked farmers
like PESTEL for patience as he tries to
renegotiate his tariffs heavy trade
policies and the farmers will be the
biggest beneficiary last month the
president announced steep taxes or
tariffs on Chinese goods China responded
with tariffs of their own on American
commodities like pork and soybeans
hitting rural agricultural states where
support for the president is high do you
support the president I do you voted for
the president yes I did and do you
support these policies which might be
hurting farmers like you I do because I
do believe long-term it'll be better for
everyone but right now we're the ones
that are taking the hit
to make up for money lost the 12 billion
dollar aid package announced Tuesday
would provide farmers with direct
financial assistance purchased their
excess produce and help develop new
export markets I mean I understand
they're trying to help us I get that but
it's it's not a long-term fix it's it's
a pacifier so to speak farmers are
self-sustaining people so is this
government aid seen as a bailout that
you'd rather not have bingo yeah I'd
rather not have it every single farmer
we've spoken to here in well County says
they don't want to take the government
aid they want to make their money by
selling their crops at fair prices and
they're willing to weather the storm to
buy the president time to negotiate
better trade deals now sign up for the
financial assistance could begin a
September for those who want to take it
Nora Adrianna great reporting thank you
so much I love when we take an issue in
Washington and actually ask people who
are affected by that issue it tells you
what it really really means and they're
speaking directly to the president
that's right